so far we have been keeping our X's and
Y's our our real and imaginary part
where you've been keeping them is nice
happy whole numbers okay now that we
have this way of stating things in
modern form you will see whole numbers
appearing somewhere less frequently
because if I want it to be in terms of
like nice angles not just nice numbers
over there it's start to appear because
all our common ratios like our exact
phrase like root 3 to 103 etc I'm going
to introduce square roots okay so don't
freak out don't think like oh why such
random number not random at all let's
have a go right I want to convert this
into monarch for what I need is two
numbers I need ah I need Pina okay so
let's work each one out in turn using
these results down here okay let's start
with the let's start with the modulus
okay because that's a pretty
straightforward thing to work out the
modulus is said okay it's gonna be the
square root all and they feel like it go
ahead and you can actually state these
just as the formula x squared plus y
squared just as you're getting it into
your brain
what are x and y in this case whatever
III I'm just reading it on okay so I'm
gonna get 1 plus 3 here yeah so this is
the square root of 4 which is 2 okay so
now right away in my head I can say how
far is this number from the origin adds
up it is 2 2 units from the origin often
an angle okay in a straight line all
right now that I know what the modulus
of Z is I can work out the angle and
it's going to feel a lot like auxiliary
angle okay because here are the two
pieces I need and I need both to work
out what angle I'm interested in okay
think about it this way yeah
I will be fine
to get to here really why am I writing
this number one because I'm starting off
I want to get the movement more like
rented these numbers come from I know
last thing you want to do is come back
to you like your first original books on
the topic to try and understand what's
going on and numbers just pop out of
thin air they don't come back a bit okay
but obviously like it's pretty trivial
to square one I just square the square
root of three
so therefore I would in normal
circumstances just go straight there
okay now what we were is worth leave
that to you I was trying to find the
argument right so my statement from the
argument comes in two forms right I know
that two sine theta is equal to now hold
on to sine theta
that's my vertical component right which
number is that that's the why isn't it
so why that's the pedicle computed there
it's root three and at the same time I
know that my horizontal component which
is R cos theta is equal to the x value
that's the horizontal a yeah okay so
from here I could say well sine theta
equals root three on to positive root
3/2 and coz theta equals 1/2 positive
half so what speed up I can say 60
degrees or what would be better is to
say it's pi/3 okay now I'm just gonna
pause it and say after I write that down
therefore theta equals PI on three
I'll ask you question your second one of
the great things about this is that if
we understand what complex numbers are
kind of we didn't need both of these
pieces right like in auxiliary angle why
did I need both pieces
why don't need that what would happen if
I only have one half like I finally have
this bother to find it
okay now in the cortex doubles in the
angle right it's like well there's more
than one solution to this right within
the domain I'm interested in for this
iPad which line is positive so I'll
either in quadrant one or according to
this is quadrant one sorry this is
quadrant one what's the corresponding
coordinate to angle it's gonna be if I
got sixty I should have 120 as well
which would be two pi on three okay okay
now why aren't there so there's two
reasons number one I have this other
part which tells me not only is sine
positive but causes positive the world
so that's my first quadrant but actually
I knew from the beginning without
knowing the second one of course I mean
the first quadrant what piece of
information tells me with the first
quadrant X adds up the first line I
wrote down right positive x positive Y
right I'm in the first quadrant so that
serves kind of like his confirmation for
you of where am I going
this ought to corroborate that you still
need to go and take this can you state
it I mean you can use tell you this in
the same way that you have beat before
you do your works in the Regal I'm still
gonna recommend that you do this because
it gets the heart off like why does tan
inverse work and the reason why is
because sine and cos are hiding behind
it okay it's marginally faster this kind
of falls into that category of yeah it's
kind of okay and you should be fine to
put that down and not ever get penalized
for it but I still don't do it so it's
up to you okay genuine question was it
that question all right all right
fantastic I have a modulus I have an
argument and it is the principal
argument so now I can state my complex
number yeah so any complex numbers
okay so she said oh there's a great
question so when you have a look at
actually know what can I can I say that
as a second example but let's just do
that as a good example we'll just finish
writing this off okay so my statement
for what is what art form is ah because
they'd applause I say Thea
okay so I know what Ari's is and I know
what theater is caused by the three plus
I sine okay happy times